on dit que par centaines de milliers les
parisiens ont déserté la capitale et que
paris l'été est une ville étrangère
c'est possible mais il y a ceux qui
restent et pour cela les plages de la
seine et de la marne s'efforce de se
voir les délices de biarritz ou d'éden
rock
il a fait si chaud que certains ont même
pensé à éviter les efforts et ceux
curieux turbopropulseurs a permis à
d'aimables baigneuse de jouer les
vedettes lance torpilles
je
sur la marne on a eu des surprises un
fuck à joinville le pont n'est pas un
spectacle courant mais il y as phoques
et phoques et le talent de ce peintre
des bords de marne explique tout
explique tout et suggère le reste
attention chat méchant la recette est
simple
de jolies jambes un bâton de rouge un
peu de fantaisie et voici de quoi
occuper vos dimanches